[Musique]
sensation sensation le mag bonjour à
tous bienvenue sur sensation en
association avec TV 78 je suis
aujourd'hui avec Clément pro directeur
de l'usine à chapeau et Fanny montgaudin
responsable communication à l'usine à
chapeau bonjour Alors l'usine à chapeau
est avant tout un lieu de vie elle est
située à Rambouillet quelle est
l'histoire justement de l'usine à
chapeau et ses ambitions sur le
territoire alors l'usine à chapeau c'est
une association qui existe depuis plus
de 60 ans à Rambouillet qui a été créé
par des habitants par des par des par
des des volontaires et des habitants à
Rambouillet pour à la fois développer
des activités en direction de la
jeunesse mais aussi en direction de la
culture des familles et de l'ensemble de
la population puis au fur et à mesure
elle a elle s'est professionnalisée
c'est structuré s'est développée et
aujourd'hui l'association c'est 60
salariés 200 bénévoles et
des activités à tous les étages c'est
une grosse association finalement et à
un énorme de vie tout au long de l'année
vous proposez des concerts aux yvelinois
alors quels sont vos ambitions justement
en termes de programmation on est
vraiment axé sur la découverte
l'émergence les artistes émergents donc
on a à la fois on a un lieu déjà dédié
au concert de musique actuelle on est
labellisé scène de musique actuelle par
le ministère de la Culture et à ce titre
là on est un lieu qui accueillant des
artistes en résidence qui viennent créer
leur spectacle leur nouveau
concert et leur nouveau spectacle dans
le dans leur ensemble chez nous on est
un lieu de diffusion on organise environ
35 concerts par an à la fois des
artistes un peu confirmés peut-être
d'affiches on va dire et puis des
artistes émergents et puis on est aussi
enfin voilà on est à la croisée des
chemins entre tous les styles de musique
sauf la musique classique qu'on laisse à
d'autres structures spécialisées mais
sinon toutes les musiques peuvent jouer
à l'usine et chapeau et l'usine à
chapeau ce n'est pas seulement des
concerts l'association propose de
nombreuses activités et activités
tournées vers la jeunesse alors est-ce
que Rambouillet justement un territoire
où les jeunes s'intéressent à la culture
alors oui enfin je crois que par
définition les jeunes s'intéressent
comme tout le monde à plein de choses et
la culture ça en fait partie
on a on a historiquement une beaucoup de
jeunes à Rambouillet puisque il y a
beaucoup de familles qui vivent beaucoup
d'enfants d'ados puis ensuite de jeunes
adultes je dirais que le segment qui
nous manque c'est les études supérieures
quoi qu'on est un ou deux une ou deux
écoles post-bac mais en gros jusqu'au
lycée il y a beaucoup de jeunes qui
fréquentent Rambouillet le lycée Bascan
est l'un des plus gros lycées
d'Île-de-France même donc on accompagne
cette jeunesse notre ADN c'est vraiment
de travailler sur les 15-25 ans on
accompagne les jeunes sur de la prise
d'initiative de de on accompagne leurs
projets on peut accompagner leur
mal-être aussi on a des une structure
une unité un peu spécialisée là-dedans
sur l'orientation l'information la
prévention voilà plein de choses pour la
jeunesse 15-25 ans à Rambouillet ou
d'ailleurs mais en tout cas pour les
jeunes qui vivent à Rambouillet au moins
une partie du temps alors justement
Fanny l'intérêt pour un territoire ou
même pour une salle de spectacle ou une
association donc comme l'usinage chapeau
l'intérêt doit justement se trouver dans
dans cette jeunesse justement dans cette
intérêt pour pour la jeunesse de la
culture
[Musique]
c'est sûr que la jeunesse a vraiment
un
opusible mais j'ai envie de dire pas que
puisque c'est une
toutes les activités qui sont proposées
et
sont enfin voilà le spectre est très
large et touche en fait
toute la population mais j'ai envie de
dire de de je vais pas dire 2-0 parce
que c'est à quelques mois quand même
on commence avec l'éveil musical à
partir de 6 mois et on a des on a des
personnes qui sont plutôt
âgées on a des gens qui vont même
jusqu'à 80 90 ans dans nos activités
donc on peut dire de 0 à 77 ans et même
boire plus donc
chaque segment de la population va
pouvoir trouver un peu un peu chaussures
à son pied dans l'association vous
l'avez bien souligné donc vous proposez
plusieurs activités aux jeunes et au
moins jeunes votre intérêt c'est surtout
de proposer un panel d'activités
finalement pour pour tous les goûts on
va parler de certaines d'entre elles
notamment des cours d'arts plastiques ou
des cours de dessin de dessin BD alors
quel est l'intérêt justement de ces
cours
c'est à la fois de
pour nous loisirs c'est pas un gros mot
et on travaille aussi sur les loisirs
pour tous c'est dans notre ADN on porte
le fait que le temps de loisirs
c'est-à-dire le temps qu'il n'est pas en
famille ou du temps d'école ou de
travail soit un temps où on apprend
aussi des choses et du coup le les
activités qu'on propose elles vont dans
ce sens là donc on dans notre dans notre
histoire on est très porté sur les
activités artistiques dans leur ensemble
alors bien sûr la musique mais aussi
justement le théâtre la danse ou les
arts plastiques et rien que dans cette
grande famille des arts plastiques on
propose plein de plein de de modules
différents que ce soit sur on a du
modèle vivant aussi par exemple pour les
gens que ça intéresse on a donc et puis
on évolue avec notre temps sur le dessin
BD sur le manga sur un certain nombre de
de nouvelles pratiques autour des arts
plastiques et on en est très contents et
en permanence on serait interroge et on
vérifie de que que ça correspond bien
aux attentes de la population de tous
les âges qui nous fréquentent et en
étant justement une salle de de
spectacle de conserve vous ne pouviez
pas passer à côté des cours de chants et
de théâtre également des cours de de
danse alors qu'elle est l'intérêt
justement pour vous de proposer ces
activités au sein de l'usine à chapeau
l'idée c'est de créer un écosystème et
que à la fois des les gens viennent chez
nous au départ bah pour apprendre une
discipline artistique donc on l'a dit on
est très axé musique on a un pôle entier
d'activités autour de la musique de la
pratique musicale mais très souvent
quand on apprend la musique on a aussi
parfois envie besoin ou de s'ouvrir sur
d'autres disciplines comme la danse
comme le théâtre et donc
au fur et à mesure on a créé du coup un
véritable écosystème et des parcours
artistiques que ce soit pour pour les
enfants les jeunes ou les adultes aussi
et que ce soit sur des activités à
l'année où toutes les semaines ils
viennent prendre un cours de d'une de
ses activités ou alors sur des stages de
manière plus ramassée et plus plus
courte pour voilà avoir quelque chose de
plus intensif si l'emploi du temps le
permet on n'aura pas assez un d'une
émission pour pour justement présenter
toutes les activités votre volonté c'est
aussi de proposer plus d'activités dans
les années à venir ou vous estimez
justement qu'il y en a aujourd'hui
suffisamment pas forcément plus
voilà mais l'idée c'est aussi de
proposer des choses qui soient qui soit
nouvelle et on est toujours en fait dans
cette recherche d'aller voir quelles
sont les dernières tendances que voilà
ce que les gens ont envie de pratiquer
etc donc voilà on fait des tentatives
comme comme tout le monde quand on
essaye des choses des fois on réussit
des fois on réussit pas mais enfin à
cœur d'essayer en tout cas et on a
justement un programme s'appelle la
découverte du samedi
ou tous les samedis on va proposer une
activité qui soit différente et on peut
venir la pratiquer quelques heures et si
ça nous plaît pour le coup on pourra la
développer la pratiquer plus à l'année
ou pas voilà ça peut être on peut avoir
envie de faire que des découvertes donc
ça c'est ça c'est un nouveau programme
qu'on est en train de mettre en place et
qui nous qui nous plaît bien et par
exemple si je reviens sur la danse là
dont vous parliez tout à l'heure on
propose prochainement alors j'ai pas
encore trop les détails parce que j'ai
entendu ça dans les tiroirs de mes
collègues mais on va proposer de la
danse en talon par exemple qui s'est
beaucoup démocratisé ces avec notamment
la personne qui a donné les cours de
danse dans la Star Academy
et voilà on a senti que c'était quelque
chose qui pouvait intéresser la
population donc on monte des programmes
on les teste on voit comment ça
fonctionne on voit s'il y a de la voilà
s'il y a de l'adhésion autour de ça et
si ça plaît en pérennise et puis et puis
voilà on essaie de s'adapter aux envies
de de chacun alors vous avez également
tout un point sur la famille la
solidarité et la citoyenneté vous
organisez des rendez-vous 1 2 3 familles
et des médiations familles alors quels
sont les objectifs justement de ces deux
dispositifs alors l'usine chapeau encore
plusieurs on le disait plusieurs
activités plusieurs agréments et on est
aussi un centre social un centre social
labellisé par la CAF des Yvelines depuis
1993 ça commence à adapter un peu mais à
ce titre là on est très engagé sur un
certain nombre de missions pour répondre
aux besoins de toute la population de du
fin de la besoin de la population du
territoire et y compris celle qui est la
plus en difficulté donc c'est à ce titre
là qu'on a des ateliers de français on a
de l'entrée scolaire on a on a un des
écrivains publics pour aider les gens à
dans leur dans leur différentes
démarches administratives on sait qu'il
y a toujours autant de démarches
administratives en France et en plus
maintenant ils sont toutes des
matérialisées sur internet donc ça crée
encore d'autres difficultés on a des on
a une une
animatrice d'atelier numérique France
service on a enfin voilà on a plein de
services comme ça où là on est tout à
fait dans le prolongement d'un service
public pour la population c'est-à-dire
qu'il y a pas besoin d'être adhérents on
vient comme on est on pousse la porte et
c'est gratuit et les questions
familiales elles sont au cœur de ça
c'est à dire qu'on accompagne aussi les
parents dans le fait d'être parents
aujourd'hui il y a beaucoup de choses
qui ont évolué d'une génération à
l'autre
on sait pas que des problèmes
d'éducation et ça on insiste aussi là
dessus les questions de parentalité
c'est pas que problème d'éducation c'est
aussi c'est aussi de savoir comment
soi-même en tant que parents on peut
continuer à vivre en tant qu'adulte tout
en étant père ou mère comment on peut
bien équilibrer les temps de vie entre
le pro le perso du temps pour soi du
temps pour sa famille et on travaille
sur toute c'est surtout toutes les
thématiques de la parentalité il y a
aussi un point accueil ecoute jeune
c'est important de le souligner merci
beaucoup Clément et Fanny d'avoir été
avec nous sur sensation pour plus
d'informations on peut se rendre sur le
site usine à chapeau point FR et pour
revoir ou réécouter cette émission
rendez-vous sur notre site et notre
application radio sensation
[Musique]